what's wrapping labels
i'm at the rent fair gonna rent it up
time to find me a dragon love conditions
[Music]
health tip if you drink out of a horn
the calories don't count
a lot of people think that the goat is
jordan
or the goat is lebron well
here's the actual goats
christians
check out the comic doing this funny
thing and putting his
balls on the neck of the people there i
love history
so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
if you eat hay from the ground you look
as fit as an elephant
it's gaming time and what's better to
gain than the original game
with his blood
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
round two fight excellent
[Music]
round three
[Music]
[Applause]
fight
round four fight
[Music]
finishing
fatality
well gamers we had a good time here at
the brim fair
we had fun we partied now we're gonna
eat some authentic medieval food
they don't pay me later gamers